في ضمن ما المعطيات التي صرح بها القيادي
في القسام هناك حول ما جرى في المغازي
هناك تسلسل يعني للاحداث ما رايك بهذا
التسلسل الذي تم الحديث عنه من قبل
القيادي في
القسام يعني بالتطابق مع ايضا قراءتك لهذا
العدد الكبير الذي جرى الاعلان عنه من
خلال الجيش جيش
الاحتلال
سلمى عندما نتحدث عن عمليه معقده وعلى
مراحل هذا امر يدل على تحضير مسبق يعني
هناك من فكر وخطط وعرف نوايا العدو
الاسرائيلي الا وهو انشاء المنطقه العازله
بعمق كيلومتر داخل قطاع غزه والحادثه التي
وقعت وقتل فيها الجنود الاسرائيليين هي
على 600 متر من الحدود فاذا هناك قرار
قياده وسيطره تحضير وانتقاء العناصر
المكلفه وبشكل ان تكون مناسبه وملائمه
لهذه العمليه هذا التسلسل شيء مهم جدا
وبالتالي عمليه الخداع يعني ان تسمح بدخول
هذه القوات مسبقا وكانك
تعرف نوايا العدو مسبقا لتخطط لها هذا
التدرج بالعمليات يدل على مستوى متقدم
وبالتالي نجاح العمليه مهما كانت حتى ولو
كانت في مكان ما يعتبر انه هناك حظ معين
ولكن دائما النتيجه هي الاساس نجحت
العمليه قلبت المقاييس التكتيكيه والعمليه
حتى الان لجيش الاسرائيلي يبقى المستوى
الاستراتيجي وبالتالي هذا الامر يعتبر
كرادع يعني اليوم هناك عمليه ممنهجه
لتدمير كل
المباني على طول ال القطاع مكان السياج
الذكي
اي بعمق كيلومتر واحد فاذا هذا الامر
سيكون رادع يعني سيكون هناك تغييرات
تكتيكيه عمليه على صعيد الحيطه والحذر من
قبل القوات الاسرائيليه وبالتالي سيفرض
صعوبات عليها قد اعود لنقطه نوعيه الردع
والمستوى الذي قد تذهب اليه مثل هذه
العمليه في ردع القوات الاسرائيليه عند
هذا الخط ولكن اريد ان اعود
لعمليه التسلسل الذي تحدثت عنه طبقا لما
جرى الاعلان عنه هناك عمليه رصد ومتابعه
ا وهناك ايضا يعني مكوث لعناصر للقسام في
المنطقه رغم القصف المستمر لمده ايام ولم
يفقدوا التواصل مع القياده من اجل الوصول
الى يعني صيد ثمين مثل مثل هذه المعطيات
بضمن عمليه قصف ما الذي تعنيه
عسكريا اولا عندما نتحدث عن الرصد والقرار
والتخطيط وتوزيع المهمات هناك مكان او
ملاز امن كي تكتمل الصوره الكبرى هذا
الملاز الامن من المفروض ان يعطي سريه
كبرى للقوات المتوفره او المتواجده
وبالتالي يحميها
لتنفيذ العمليه في نفس الوقت هناك عده
عمليات حصلت وكانها عمليات لف نظر
وتمويه عن العمليه الاساسيه والتي حصلت في
اسقاط المبنى ثلاثه وهون الامر المهم هو
عمليه استراتيجيه الخروج او ما يسمى
بالايت ستراتيجي يعني هي دائره من التخطيط
الى القرار الى التنفيذ ومن ثم عمليه
الخروج او الا استراتيجي وبالتالي هناك
استثمار سلمى هناك استثمار قليل جدا اراده
تي بي جي او ار بي جي او ايا كان استثمار
بسيط جدا وهدف كبير
جدا له تداعيات استراتيجيه على كل ما يجري
في قطاع غزه وبالتالي على الداخل
الاسرائيلي السياسي والعسكري والمعنوي
وحتى النفسي هذا هو اهميه هذا الامر فاذا
انت بعم يه معقده استطعتي ان تنتجي مردودا
استراتيجيا بتنفيذ تكتيكي بسيط وليس
بالضروره ان يكون من نفذ او قائد هذه
العمليه له علاقه او يتصل مباشره بالقياده
الاساسيه بسبب سريه المعلومه هذا يعني
هناك حريه تنفيذ معين ولكن هكذا عمليه
بهكذا حجم يجب ان تكون من مستوى متقدم
ا ايضا مصدر قيادي في القسام يتحدث بانه
رصد المجاهدون القوه المعاديه تتقدم وتم
تشخيصها على انها قوه هندسيه عبر هويتها
ومعداتها والعدو كثف نيرانه بالمنطقه وقام
بتمشيط حتى ظن انها اصبحت امنه فادخل قوات
الهندسه يعني هنا الى اي درجه عامل
الخديعه في موضوع يعني يعني جيش الاحتلال
ودخوله وحديثه بانه فعليا يقاتل اشباح على
الارض
هذا الامر قاله
قائد الفرقه 99 في في في جنوب غزه عندما
قال نقاتل فوق الارض تحت الارض
و720 درجه وليس 360 360 درجه عندما نتحدث
عن هذه المنطقه هذه المنطقه من المفروض ان
لا يكون فيها اي وجود لقوات المقاومه فاذا
هناك تطمين
اسرائيلي لجيش الاحتلال على ان هذه
المنطقه امنه ولكن احتياطا بدا الجيش
الاسرائيلي جيش الاحتلال يقصف تمهيدا او
ما يسمى بالكارت بومين يعني القصف المكثف
لتامين قدوم هذه الفرقه عاده قوات الهندسه
تحمل العتاد وتحمل امور متعلقه بالامور
التقنيه والمتعلق بالمتفجرات وهي لا تملك
الدبابات هي لدي
من يحميها من هنا كان استهداف الميركافا
التي تؤمن الحمايه فاذا هم لديهم هذه
المنظومه ولكن المؤشرات التكتيكيه تدل عن
وظيفه وحموله هذه الفرقه التي اتت لتفجير
هذا المكان وبالتالي وكان العمليه كانت
محضره مسبقا فاذا هناك تناسب بين ما
حضرته عناصر المقاومه والقوه المتقدمه
يعني لو سلمنا جدلا وك كان العكس ان هناك
كتيبه او لواء مدرع يتقدم بهذه المنطقه لم
يكن لقليل من عناصر المقاومه ان تفتح
المعركه معها بسبب خلل في التوازن وبسبب
القدره لعدم القدره على تغيير ايه موازين
القوى ولكن هذه القوه هي ليست بالقوه
المحميه لها وظيفه معينه تريد ان تفجر ما
لديها حمايه ليست قويه ومن المفروض ان
تكون هذه المنطقه كما قلت خاليه من قوات
المقاومه حدث
ما وسيعتبر هذا رادعا لاي
شيء رادعا رادعا نح نعم سيعتبر هذا الامر
رادعا كيف للمرحله القادمه وسيعتبر ان كل
بيت هو مفخخ وكل بيت هناك من يتربص ويجب
عليهم ان يدخلوه وبالتالي تنظيفه وهذا امر
ياخذ وقت وقد يكون هناك قتل منهم عمليه
الر هذه هي مهمه يعني خاصه باذا ما اردنا
الحديث عن الاثار لمثل هذه العمليه
النوعيه التي شكلت منعطفا في هذه المعارك
الجاريه
في عفوا القطاع هناك اثر عسكري وهناك اثر
مباشر عملياتي وهناك ايضا اثر
معنوي اشرح لنا اكثر عن هذه الاثار
المباشره
لها
الجيش الاسرائيلي في عقيدته الكبرى
التاريخيه هناك مثلث اساسي يعتمد عليه
يعني ان يردع وهذا الامر سقط في غزه ان
يكون لديه الانذار المبكر وفي كل الامور
المعينه من الجدران ومن السياج وحتى
الاتفاقات الامنيه كم ديفيد والملحقات
الامنيه تتعلق بالانذار المبكر وثالث امر
مهم هو الحسم ه هذه الامور كلها سقطت في
غزه وعلى الجيش الاسرائيلي او القياده
الاسرائيليه اليوم تبحث عن معادله
استراتيجيه جديده تعيد الردع ولكن الردع
الاسرائيلي اليوم هو مدى الدمار مدى القتل
اما الردع من قبل المقاومه هو الردع
التدريجي المتراكم يعني انت تمنع العدو من
ان يحقق الاهداف عبر الصمود عبر خساره
المسافه والمساحه مقابل كسب الوقت وانزال
اكبر قدر ممكن من الخسائر هذا الامر
سينعكس مباشره على اسرائيل لماذا لانه
نتحدث عن قطاع غزه ملامس مباشره لغلاف غزه
دخلت المقاومه عليها 600 مكم مربع اثنين
حتى لو الجيش الاسرائيل لجيش الاحتلال
انشا المنطقه العازله بيكفي صاروخ واحد
فقط ان يغير كل المعادله الامنيه من هنا
سعي الجيش الاسرائيلي الى ضرب هذه
الصواريخ او المنصات فاذا انت المقاومه
تقوم بعمليه ردع متراكم الى درجه معينه
كان يصبح ال الخسائر لا تناسب القرارات
السياسيه ليكون التغيير سياسي حتى الان لم
يقتنع نتنياهو ان الحل هو بالتفاوض هو
بالانسحاب مقابل اخلاء الرهائن وا الاسرى
فاذا عمليه تراكميه حماس بالموازين القوى
سلمى هناك ما يسمى بالردع يعني اذا اخذنا
دولتين عظمتين هناك ما يسمى ردع لانه هناك
في توازن نووي او نووي مقابل نووي اليوم
نتحدث عن واحد مقابل عشره عندما يختل
الميزان التقني دائما دائما سلمى في
الحروب المهمه هو الكيف هو التعديلات
والابتكارات التكتيكيه لانزال اكبر قدر
ممكن من الخ فنتحدث عن النفق مثلا لو دخل
ج هل جيش الاحتلال قادر على هذا النوع من
التكيف خاصه بعد ما شهده بهذه
العمليه التكيف دائما هناك دائره للقرار
يعني هناك
التجربه اخذ الدروس ادخال هذه الدروس
بالعمليه او بالعقيده التكتيكيه التي يتم
فيها المقاومه حتى ولو تم خفض قدراتها كما
تقول نيويورك تايمز بين 20 او 30% تظل
قادره لانه دائره القرار دائره لامركزيه
قادره على ادخال هذه الدروس مباشره
والتنفيذ اما في الجيش الاسرائيلي فهو جيش
معقد جيش كبير لديه الهندسه والطيران وعده
اسلحه يستلزم وقت كي يتدرب ويدخل هذه
الدروس المستقاه في عقيدته العسكريه هو
يتعلم كلما تقدم دم الدروس وكلما تقدم كل
متر يتقدمه هناك واقع جديد هناك مرحله
زئبقيه وبالتالي عليه ان يتدرب ويتعلم
كلما تقدم ولكن دائما ثمن التقدم تجعله
المقاومه ثمنا دمويا يدفعه وهذا ما حصل في
تفجير المبنى وهذه السيوله في الانماط
القتاليه التي
يتبعها
مقاوم الكتائب
المقاومه على الارض برايك
كيف ستتطور خاصه مع وصول القتال الى منطقه
خان يونس في هذه المنطقه
الجنوبيه منطقه خانيونس هي مركز الثقل
الاساسي من هنا تركيز جيش الاحتلال على
ثمانيه الويه تقاتل في خانيونس اليوم
المرحله المهمه بالنسبه له هو الاشتباك مع
بني سهيله عبسان الجديده عبسان خز خزاعه
تم تدمير خزاعه بسبب احدى اهم الاسباب هو
لانشاء هذه المنطقه العازله اليوم يريد
مركز الثقل الاساسي يعتبر ان قيادات حماس
موجوده فيها يعتبر ان الرهائن والاسرى
موجودين فيها ويعتبر ان اذا كانت كل
القيادات موجوده في خان يونس لابد ان يكون
هناك مركز وقلب شبكه الانفاق التي تذهب
بكل الاتجاهات ولكن يبقى هل هو قادر هل هو
فعلا والانفاق عاده سلمى تعطي ما يسمى
بالفلوت
بالانسياب لعناصر المقاومه لانها قادره ان
تقاتل فوق الارض وتحت الارض وتعطيهم هذه
الانسيابيه والخروج حتى العمل على ضرب
خطوط الامداد للعدو من هنا جيش الاحتلال
يقوم بعمليه انزال وهي خامس مره منذ اسبوع
تقريبا على غرب خانيونس
للفرقه المؤ الفرقه المظليه اها واللافت
ايضا بان المقاتلين انسحبوا بسلام وايضا
هناك صور حصل عليها حصلت عليها القسام
وكنا قد
اي بثث اناها قبل قليل لعمليه تفخيخ منازل
في القطاع من قبل قوات الاحتلال كيف تفسر
عمليه الحصول على مثل هذه الفيديوهات ما
هي الاحتمالات برايك لحصول اي الكتائب
المقاومه على هذا الفيديو الذي ظهر معنا
قبل
قليل سلمى هذه عمليه تكهن حدث هذا الامر
اعتقد على ما اتذكر في الشجاعيه او الشيخ
رضوان عندما استدرجت قوات العدو الى
ايه الى فتحه نفق وبالتالي كانت الكاميرات
مركبه مسبقا عليها وبالتالي كان هناك ما
يسمى بالريل تايم او الريل فيد يعني اذا
كان الجيش الاسرائيلي يبعث او يرسل الكوت
كوبتر لنقل صوره المعركه كانت هذا الامر
صوره المعركه موجوده يعني هناك قدرات
سيبرانيه وتقنيه ل عناصر المقاومه هل من
الممكن ان يكون وضعت كاميرات مسبقا في هذا
المبنى قبل دخول القوات الاسرائيليه اما
اعتراضها يعني انا اقول انه الاعت راض
السيبراني هو عامل مسيء ومضر ايضا
للمقاومه في وقت من الاوقات لانه اذا انت
دخلت سيبرانيا على جزء اخر هذا الجزء
الاخر ممكن ان يعرف مكانك ويتنس عليك او
يعمل هاكن كما يقال يعني انا اعتقد انه هل
يكون هناك كاميرات مرقبه مسبقا ام ان يكون
يعني على سبيل المثال الحصر منذ منذ يومين
او ثلاثه عندما اسقطت الطائره الكوات
كوبتر وكان فيها شريحه هذه الشريحه تم
نقلها تحليلها
استنتاج اهداف معينه للتجمعات الاسرائيليه
وبالتالي استهدافها بالمدفعيه الهواوي
ولكن هذا الامر يدل على ان العدو
الاسرائيلي من المفروض ان لا يكون هناك
شريحه ومن المفروض ان تكون هذه الشريحه
مجفر ولكن هو ياخ ياخذها كما يقال اوبن
سورس انه مفتوحه لمن يشاء فاذا استفادت
منها المقاومه هذا امر مهم جدا على صعيد
الاستعلام الثلاثه والاهم كما ايضا سلمى
هو وعي المكان يعني افضليه المكان او ما
يسمى بالانجليزيه الهوم كورت يعني هو
يقاتل في منزله في بيته والذي نفذ
عمليه التفجير هذا المبنى اعتقد انه من
الكتائب في وسط القطاع او حول المخيمات
التي استهدفتها اسرائيل